good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to welcome
our speaker dr russ poldrack the albert ray
lang professor of psychology and professor
of computer science at stanford university
dr poldrack completed his bachelor's degree
in psychology from baylor university in 1989
and his phd in experimental psychology from the
university of illinois at urbana-champaign in
1995 working closely with neil j cullen from
1995 to 1999 he was a postdoctoral fellow at
stanford university working closely with john
gabrielli in his professional experience prior
to his appointment at stanford in 2014 he held
faculty positions at harvard medical school
at ucla and at the university of texas at austin
uh he has been the pi on numerous nih-funded and
nsf-funded grants in brain research the modeling
of cognitive ontologies as well as the fields of
neuroinformatics and data science he's been
awarded a distinguished scientific award in
early career contributions to psychology from the
american psychological association he was awarded
the wiley young investigator award from the
organization for human brain mapping in 2005 and
is a fellow of the association for psychological
sciences elected in 2009 he's also served as the
chairperson of the organization for human brain
mapping he is the founder and co-editor of the
uh frontiers in brain imaging methods and he was
the chair of the external advisory panel for the
human connectome project and a member of advisory
panels for the adolescent brain and cognitive
development study as well as the the cavily
human study the work from his laboratory involves
functional neuroimaging the study of learning
and memory executive function decision making the
notions of reverse inference as well as the
pursuits in neuroinformatics data science
data sharing and reproducible and responsible
science his lecture today is entitled towards
a culture of computational reproducibility and as
always we are streaming this lecture live uh and
for recording via youtube and if you're watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are encouraged
to submit any questions for dr podrak by the chat
feature in your zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of dr paul drax's
lecture and with that welcome russ thank you so
much we are really looking forward to your lecture
all right well thanks very much for the invitation
happy to be here and hello to everybody on youtube
um so i want to talk today about kind of moving
towards a culture of reproducibility and when i
talk about reproducibility i'm primarily focusing
on what people often refer to as computational
reproducibility um you know this is ping's uh kind
of spectrum of reproducibility on on the one hand
you have kind of you know like full replication
like a new study new data um i'm going to focus on
kind of just before that the idea of you know
kind of sharing everything that goes into an
analysis and simply being able to reproduce
the results that one finds now now obviously
you know in the end we want to be able to
generalize out to new data and and new you
know new analysis code as well and i'll talk some
about that but the the point here i want to make
here is i'm really focusing on reproducibility as
sort of um not quite all the way to replication
but simply taking a a completed study and you know
showing that we can reproduce the results now um
you know a lot of my thinking is inspired by this
quote from david donahoe a statistician here at
stanford he was really one of the pioneers of kind
of reproducible data science who said an article
about a computational result is advertising
not scholarship the actual scholarship is
the full software environment code and data that
produce the result so why is this a problem well
you know first in many different domains data
analysis today is highly complex and offers an
extreme degree of flexibility in the way that one
can do one analyses and it's generally impossible
to reproduce a result just using the publication
and even with the code and the data it can be
different difficult to reproduce the results so
i want to sort of talk through an example of this
from a study that i did a few years ago
this was a study where i had scanned myself
repeatedly over the course of a year and a half
collected you know blood data did rna sequencing
um and then we published a paper where we
tried to build a reproducible analysis workflow
and we did this using a technology called
virtual machines which is basically building
sort of a a little computer inside a computer
that should look exactly the same way for
anybody who runs it and so we gave this out
and basically said hey if you run this thing
you install it in your computer and
run it you know it'll take a few hours
and ultimately you'll have all the same results
that we used in the that we report in the paper
so i get an email maybe a year later hi i'm
an undergraduate student at johns hopkins i'm
trying to you know reproduce your results i've run
into some trouble reproducing the rna seek results
they're supposed to be 63 coexpression modules
but when i run the scripts i only get 60. i reran
the analysis with the vm and the real result is
60. um essentially the same code is run on the
same data but arrives at two different results
what might be going on and it turns out that if
you look at the version of the r package that we
used to do that analysis in the paper it was 1.47
by the time you know he went to run
the analysis it was version 1.51 and it
turns out that our virtual machine pulled
the latest version of the code and that
little change from 1.747 to 1.51 resulted in
differences in the results of the analysis
even though we had this like fully reproducible
in theory uh analysis platform we also know that
you know small differences can actually have
impact on analysis results this is some work
from tristan guitard a few years ago showing
that if you run free surfer on uh on structural
imaging data you can get different results either
between different linux versions or even between
different software builds which they ultimately
track down to particular numeric libraries
um so that's that's one sort of set of concerns
around uh you know the platform dependence and the
version dependence of results another has to do
with software errors so um you know much of what
we do as scientists is really amateur software
engineering right and the question is how likely
are we to make errors if you look at professional
software developers on their first submission of
code they across studies make anywhere from
150 errors per thousand of lines of code
so how many errors do we think we make as amateur
software developers um and how likely are they to
impact our scientific conclusions well we know
of examples where this has happened um one comes
from the work of jeffrey chang he was a structural
biologist who published a bunch of papers in the
early 2000s about this particular protein the
abc transporter and ended up having to retract
five papers because there was a piece of code that
they used they'd actually gotten from someone else
that ended up causing a sine flip that caused
the wrong uh handedness of the protein structures
and a particular concern is you know what some of
us have started calling bug hacking which is the
idea that um when you know bugs aren't neutral
in terms of you know our likelihood of finding
them right if we have a bug that disconfirms
our predictions it gives us results that we
quote unquote don't like we're much more
likely to dig in and sort of find that bug
than if we have a bug that gives us the
results that we're expecting or sort of
gives us results that are better than they
actually should be so i'm going to argue
that we need to develop a culture of computational
reproducibility that everything that we do needs
to be sort of focused on how we can do science
that's computationally reproducible and i'm i'm
going to lay this out in terms of um an idea that
that was inspired by reading uh kent beck's work
on extreme programming where he talks about
a culture of of you know software development
um and so that which it sort of frames it around
the idea of values principles and practices so
what and um this this idea of culture is also
you know sort of highlighted in the the work
but from the national academies a couple years
ago where they said recommendation number one
research institute should work to create a culture
that actively supports open science by design and
reproducibility is part of that so what are these
values that i talk about well the first should be
objectivity right which basically means
we want to get the answers right and one
objectivity is a complex concept in the philosophy
of science and one one way that i like that people
talk about it is in terms of minimizing what
you might think of as epistemic risk the risk
of having incorrect knowledge um another value
is community you know we think that science
should be a communal rather than a competitive
endeavor third is respect that the community
should be open and inclusive and respect the
contributions and positionality of each individual
fourth is humility we have to acknowledge the
fact that we're humans and everything we do has
biases and limitations and then there's also
constraints on the generality of our work
fifth value is openness our work should be
available to others to reproduce and use and um
six is transparency our work should be clear and
understandable to others so then the question is
how do we turn those values into principles um
now you might be asking why is he talking about
like you know openness and inclusivity
here and you know there are clearly
humanistic reasons that you know that we want to
be open and inclusive and diverse um but there's
also good reasons from the philosophy of science
and this is um a quote from helen longino who's a
feminist philosopher of science who has laid
out this argument that you know why does
why does science work right and one of her
arguments is that science works exactly
because it's a social phenomenon that takes ideas
and puts them up to scrutiny and so this is a
quote from her when background assumptions
are shared by all members of a community
they acquire an invisibility that renders them
but unavailable for criticism they don't become
visible until individuals who don't share
the community's assumptions can provide
alternative explanations of phenomena without
those assumptions as for example einstein could
provide an alternative explanation of the
michelson-morley interferometer experiment
because he didn't share the assumption of the
variable speed of light from all this again it
follows that the greater the number of different
points of view included in a given community the
more likely it is that scientific practice will
be objective and result in descriptions and
explanations of natural processes that are more
reliable than would otherwise be the case okay
so what are the principles that we're going to use
to kind of you know guide the practices well one
is going to be diversity we want a community to
be as diverse inclusive and equitable as possible
we're going to build around community standards we
need we want our work to be structured by a common
understanding of what best practices are we want
to sort of highlight the role of reflection on our
on our own practices so following feynman's quote
that the first principle is that you must not fool
yourself and you are the easiest person to
fool and i'm going to focus on the idea of
errors as sort of the best learning experiences
um a fourth principle is continuous improvement
the idea that you know that everything we do but
particularly software development is a skill that
we have to continuously and deliberately hone and
fifth is a principle of portability the idea that
any analysis should be repeatable at different
times across different systems you can think of
reproducibility at some in some way as like you
know portability in time so finally i'm gonna i'm
gonna walk through a set of practices and this is
gonna be the meat of the talk um i'm gonna first
talk about how building and nurturing a community
second about how coding for reproducibility
third about sharing and openness and forth
about automation so first building a community
so you know everybody talks about how they want to
collaborate but um there's more to collaboration
than simply you know sort of exchanging knowledge
and having a common goal across teams and this is
a illustration from the touring way which is
a really nice um project from the alan turing
institute that lays out a bunch of you know
thoughts about how to build open inclusive
diverse collaborative teams i i definitely would
would recommend having a look at that resource um
so the one of the important aspects of building
an open community is um making it clear how people
can become a part of the community and contribute
um and and one of the things one can do there is
giving out guidelines to so this is an example
of um for our fmri prep project which is a
data pre-processing workflow for fmri data we lay
out uh basically you know one why you know how can
somebody contribute why should they contribute
and then get a lot of details about the specific
ways in which you know a person can go about
contributing um and you know really trying to
make the project as as open and inviting as
possible to anybody with any set of skills
you know making it clear you don't have to be
like a you know a super expert coder to contribute
second is codes of conduct making it clear
that you know we want to build a community
that's opening open and welcoming to everybody
um and that's harassment free and so this is
our fm right prep code of conduct there's a
lot of you know various codes of conduct that
are available out there to kind of to crib from
and that's what we did here but just basically
making it clear what do you what are you expected
to how are you expected to behave as part of this
community now you know a lot of these practices
have been put in place in um hackathons and you
know hackathons are common in lots of different
areas um you know i have experience with the
ones in neuroscience in particular um the brain
hack which has been you know held around the um
the ohbm meeting for the last few years um cameron
craddick has you know has been one of the the main
organizers along here bellac and others and
has written a paper recently about this idea
and really you know what they do is they try to
bring people in through educational experiences
and get them involved in community through
you know working together on hacking projects
and this is kirsty whitaker having a lot of
fun at the brain hack a couple years ago um
so so i think that you know the the brain
imaging community is uh has given us like
a really nice example of like how this sort
of like open science community that's kind
of you know diverse and open and welcoming can
actually work um and so i definitely would would
invite all of you to take part actually
brain hack global is happening right now
so um so i don't know like you can probably still
sort of get involved in it um but certainly in the
future you know becoming involved in hackathons
is a great way to sort of start working to build
this community all right so now let's talk about
how to code for reproducibility um and um there's
a number of features that are important
for writing high quality code right one is
that it needs to be readable um and i'll talk
more about this second is it needs to be robust it
needs to you know run across different platforms
and get the same answer it needs to be modular
uh both for reusability and also for easier
testability and finally it needs to be well tested
and i want to highlight the fact that you know
coding is a craft right many people have hobbies
you know i play guitar and the only way you
get better at playing guitar is by practicing
similarly the only way you get better at
coding is by consistent and deliberate
practice and this is highlighted in the
fact that you know the software carpentry
sort of uses this analogy directly right that we
you need to uh you need to to practice the skills
just as you would if you're going to become a
carpenter so it turns out that there's you know
a good bit that's known from software engineering
about you know how to build better software
so you know what what's striking is you
know even in commercial software development
about 40 to 50 and this is written a few years
ago i don't know if these numbers have changed
a lot they probably have with the advent of of
better software engineering practices about 40
to 50 percent of the effort is spent on avoidable
rework this is professional software developers
during development almost no modules are defect
free as they've been implemented in post release
this is after they've been reviewed about
40 percent of modules may be defect-free
that meaning the majority of them still have
defects peer reviews can catch about 60 of
the defects and discipline disciplined personal
practices can reduce defect rates by up to 75
so what are some of those practices well the
first that you know that i think everybody
should be using and most of you are probably
familiar with is version control if you have
programmed without using version control you're
probably accustomed to seeing file names like this
where you basically have embedded
the version control in the file name
version control pro you know using
tools like git and github provides a
a much better way to to track what's been
done with code it also provides a really
nice and and easy way to experiment uh using
branches um and so if you're not familiar with
git i would suggest maybe starting with the um the
software carpentry uh modules on on git and github
which are really nice um another thing that i
think gets less you know many people are familiar
with version control i think many few people or
many fewer people are familiar with coding style
and coding style is really important because
you know as the founder of python guido van
rossum said code is read much more often
than it's written so readability counts now
nearly every language has a language specific
convention for coding style and following those
conventions makes your code easier for others
to read and understand and it's important to
keep in mind that others includes your future self
right when you look back at code six months from
now it's as if you are a different person and so
if the code is readable you'll be you'll be much
more easily able to figure out what on earth was i
trying to do there now there's also a lot of sort
of language independent principles of software
design i'm showing a few of the books here that
that i found useful um i think as a starting
point um this book called the art of readable code
is probably a great starting point for just
learning sort of language independent principles
of how to how to write good code that may
focus a lot on kind of making it understandable
now you know we mentioned the idea that uh code
review can find lots of bugs um and um this sort
of fits with linus's law from linus torvald given
enough eyeballs all bugs are shallow right if
enough people look at code um the bugs are gonna
pop out to somebody and so the idea of code review
for scientific code has been around for a long
time uh petrie and wilson wrote about this you
know a number of years ago um but i think there's
increasing interest recently you know there's just
a twitter thread a couple days ago about this with
a number of people chiming in about how they've
started implementing this you know in their
labs but this paper lays out kind of some nice
ideas about how to implement this we've started
implementing code review regularly in our lab
meetings roughly once a month we take somebody's
code and sort of walk through it and do a review
um so another you know important thing that i
think gets less uh notice in scientific code is
testing so any function that does something
important should be tested um one it should make
sure that you know you know what the code should
do and you want to write tests that make sure it
does the things properly you also want to make
sure that like in the in the occasions when the
code should like you know raise an error that it
actually does that right that it doesn't sort of
just give you you know garbage out for garbage
in now most languages have powerful testing
frameworks you know i'm familiar with the ones in
python and r um martin fowler who's you know the
one of the kind of you know deans of software
engineering says whenever you're tempted to
type something into a print statement or debugger
expression write it as a test instead and we we
often in my lab try to use something there's an
idea called test driven development and we don't
do this kind of you know kind of rigorously
but the idea is like if you want to know if
something's working rather than kind of you know
just like trying it out on your on your own typing
it into your to your console just build a test
every time you want to check that something is
working build a new test for it use the test
framework and then you'll have those tests
around as you add new features to make sure that
you haven't broken anything now a corollary to
this is that whenever there are well-established
libraries to do something you should use them
um you know engineers often get sort of sucked
in by this thing that people refer to as the
nih of the not invented here effect in which they
they think that they need to build a new solution
that's homegrown rather than use an existing
solution and my favorite example of this is the
the large number of dicom to nifty converters that
exist in the neural imaging field um so you know
whenever there's an existing package it's much
better to use that package and if you need to add
features contribute fixes or extensions to that
existing package you know become part of that
development community rather than trying to roll
your own and you also want to prefer libraries
that use good software engineering practices
that have you know and this is sort of seen
for example in scikit-learn through all the you
know the badges like the fact that it has 96
code coverage 96 of the code is being tested it's
passing various versions of python for example
so testing is a deep rabbit hole but there's some
pretty simple things one can do the simplest is
assertions basically just making sure that
if some if you know something to be true
make sure it's true um here's an example of a
case where that could have saved somebody a good
bit of pain this is a paper that was published
in plos one they shared their data because you
have to plus one and somebody realized
after looking at the data hey there's uh
this is supposed to be data from adults
there's two subjects one with age five
one with age three two seven five seven and um
that when you fix those that changes the results
had they simply you know put in an
assertion saying hey we need to assert that
the age is between say you know 6 and 120 that
would have caught that issue now we also want
to make sure that our code is actually giving
us the right answer um and you know before so
to validate code a couple things to think about
are one what we call parameter recovery which
is basically before you ever analyze real data
analyze you know generate some synthetic data
where you know what the answer should be and make
sure that your code can recover the known answer
like i said best to do that before you ever touch
the real data the other is null or randomization
testing where you generate data where you
know that there's no effect either by you know
synthetic data or by randomizing real data and
make sure that you're that your analysis says hey
there's no effect here's a place where that might
have been useful so this was a paper published
a few years ago claiming to have you know very
high accuracy in a very small sample of decoding
you know different uh classes of of cognitive
impairment using diffusion imaging so they turns
out that they what they did they did a feature
selection step prior to cross validation which um
we know to be problematic it's sort of basically
kind of a double dipping you're using the data to
pick the best features and then using those
features to actually do your cross validation
this is a simulation that i ran showing basically
what happens you know what is accuracy when you do
feature selection within the cross validation
which comes out here you know right around point
five on average when you do the feature
selection and then do cross validation
you get accuracy so often perfect or you know
around point nine um so basically just you know
had they done some simple simulations to look at
the effect of their um of their procedures they
would have seen hey this is really problematic
um so you know despite all of our best efforts
we're going to make errors in our code and
so what matters is how we respond to them
when we discover them so we had an issue recently
where we had we've done a large analysis of the
abcd data set the behavior on the data set
identified some issues with the stop signal data
made our code available with the um with the
preprint and the abcd team dug into this and
realized we had made an error um in the code
in this like really complex boolean operation
and when we fixed it it changed the numbers
it didn't change the overall kind of take
away the paper but it definitely changed the
numbers in the paper um so what we did was um
you know we obviously we fixed the the preprint
um and the code but we also try to use this error
as a teachable moment taking as a model this
idea of the morbidity immortality conference
which is something that's done regularly at
academic medical centers where um basically
the idea is not to criticize but to profit
from sharing and examining experience in a
blame-free environment focusing on either like
poor intended outcomes that might have been due
to due to or worsened by error or system problems
or talking about near-misses where something
bad almost happened and importantly there's no
finger pointing right it's really figuring out
how do you how might you fix the causes rather
than kind of focusing on the errors that people
made in particular focusing on sort of the
root causes right so when we've done this
thinking through you know thinking about where
errors have come from sometimes you know that can
include programming error programmer error right
they increa incorrectly index that data frame
um it could be a dependency right there's a
bug and a package that i was relying on and as
as in the um the steve chang case um it could
also be a systemic cause so for example you know
we were in a hurry because we needed to get the
paper submitted before you know blah blah blah
so that helps figure out how can
we in the future avoid errors
okay i'm gonna talk now about sharing so you know
most of our work is paid for by taxpayers and we
owe it to them to maximize the benefits of their
support we also owe it to our research subjects to
human or non-human to maximize the benefits of
their participation and we owe it to the world
to maximize the benefits of the carbon that we're
burning you know running our supercomputers so one
really important thing is is sharing code you
know many people are kind of you know bashful
about sharing their code because they're not
um they're not professional programmers they're
worried that somebody's gonna find a problem with
it the question you might wanna ask yourself is
if your code is not good enough to share then
why do you think it's good enough to use to
publish the results that rely upon it and nick
barn made this this case nicely a few years ago
arguing that you know everybody should publish
their code it's it's if it's good enough to
to use for science it's good enough to publish now
many people including us you know would publish
code just by giving a link to a github repository
this is from a paper we published last year
um there's an issue with this right so imagine
that you know we i we put that link in if somebody
goes here you know changes have been made to
that code since the paper was published how do
they know exactly which version we used if we if
they want to reproduce those results and what if
you know ian eisenberg decides to delete the
repository and those the code goes away so what we
now like to do is um share data using a persistent
identifier which basically provides a link to that
material that guarantees that it's not going to go
away the you're probably familiar with doi digital
object identifier it's it's actually very easy
to get a doi for code if you um if your code is
on github and use this thing called zenodo which
is a data sharing repository that's run by cern
in switzerland um you basically just sign up
for xenodo login using your github account um
and then link your github repository to your to
that you want to share to that zonoto account
and then anytime you create a release on github
which basically says this is a kind of a frozen
release of the of the repository um that will
automatically be turned into a release on
that's shared on zanodo and that has a doi um so
even if github were to you know god forbid go away
those data will still be the sort of the code
will still be there on sunodo for somebody to
to obtain and then finally you can put
that in your paper so here's from our
recent nature paper we say fully reproducible code
for all the analyses is available here at this doi
so it gives you a persistent identifier
that's not going to change or go away
now whenever you share anything it's important
to have a license associated with it that this
basically tells people what they can do with the
the stuff that you're sharing in general you want
to choose the most permissive license you can or
the one that's used by your research community
if you work with a bunch of people who use a
particular license it's probably good to use that
one and people often think that non-commercial
lysing licensing sounds like a good idea um
but it rarely is um and importantly because
the the meaning of non-commercial is actually
not really clear i mean it ends up greatly
limiting reuse even by people who you might
want to be able to reuse it so you have to
ask your question if if if somebody actually
violated the license would you pursue legal
action if not then then you certainly don't
want to put a non-commercial license because
you're basically you know wasting your time
now i think we probably all agree that sharing
data is alongside our code is essential for
reproducibility it's really easy to share
data badly um if you haven't seen this cartoon
data sharing and management snafu in
three acts i would uh suggest you go
to youtube and and search around for that
because it's a pretty humorous little uh
extra normal cartoon about basically how to share
data badly um so one of the important aspects of
data sharing is organizing the data in a way
that other people can easily use it and using
an accepted standard in one's research community
is the best way to do that so we've been involved
for the last few years in building something
called the brain imaging data structure or bids
which is a standard for organizing both the data
and the metadata of a neuroimaging study and
the idea is like if you you know if you share
your data in that format then other people can
easily use it and if you actually organize your
data in that format format from the beginning
um one remember that you know share it you're also
sharing your data with yourself in the future so
when you go back and look at a data set next
year you'll like you'll be able to understand
it more easily if it's in the standard format
and it also then takes very little extra work
to share the data if you're in other domains so
for electrophysiology there's a standard called
neurodata without borders for psychological data
sets there's an emerging standard called psycds
so the important thing is to find the standard
that works for your data and use it it's also
important to version data right because just as
you want to know exactly what version of the code
was used you know data change people find errors
they add you know variables and so on so one
thing you can do you know for smaller data sets
we've used git and github on some occasions and
one way you can version something
on github is basically to give the
the commit id which is a little hash that
basically refers to a specific version of the code
again we think it's better to use a repository
that actually provides uh persistent identifiers
so for example if you want to share from
right there you can upload it to open neuro
and that will give you for a specific version
of the data set which is like a snapshot of
frozen snapshot of the data you can get a doi
pointing to that particular version so people can
know exactly what version of the data set you use
for your analyses now licensing shared data is a
little tricky because the legal status of data
with regard to copyright is complicated most
most data not really copyrightable but nonetheless
any shared data should always have a terms of use
which people often kind of call a license
associated with it so that other people know
exactly what they're allowed to do with the
data we generally prefer the most permissive
uh agreement which is called a public domain
dedication or as often referred to as a cc0
license which basically allows pretty much anybody
to do anything they want with it and you know
obviously we i think we have a community agreement
that if you're going to use someone's data
you're going to cite that person you know in in
the paper um so another thing that we need to be
able to share is the platform i mentioned before
how you know the platform can make a difference
sharing encoded the code and data is not enough
and so we've begun to focus heavily on the idea
of containerization for um for sharing platforms
and the idea behind containerization is really to
sort of allow you to exactly reproduce not
just the code but the entire platform that
that the code runs on and so the the technology
that we and most people are kind of you know
focusing on these days is this thing called docker
which is a you know an open openly available
package that basically allows you to define a
computing environment that basically says you know
what libraries and software packages do i need and
i can say what specific versions of them i want
um that basically defines your platform for
computing and then you can basically give that
definition to somebody else and they can recreate
that exactly and run the code in sort of exactly
as close a way as is computationally possible
modulo things like floating point weirdness
containers are nice one for like you know sharing
what you've done they also make it really easy
for other people to run your code so i mentioned
fmri prep which is this pre-processing pipeline
that we've developed um you know if you want to
run it from my prep which is a you know a big
package that requires lots of dependencies
you could install all those dependencies
install the package run the package um but
if you have the docker software installed
which is available for pretty much every
platform this you can basically run fmri prep
using this single command and what it will do is
go pull this specific version poldrack fmri prep
20.2.0 specific version of our package from our
um our repository on what's called docker hub um
and run that thing without you having to install
anything it'll basically grab it run it uh run
that specific version and um and you're guaranteed
to have it run as reproducibly as possible
now one challenge is that you can't use docker on
most high performance computing systems because
it requires root access in order to to run it but
there's a another package another project called
singularity that allows you to run containers
on high performance computing systems um
so for example um you know we have a system
at stanford called sherlock and you know if
you have a docker image you can basically use
singularity to run that docker image on uh on
the high performance computing system we found
this to be really handy because you know we run
you know analyses on a number of different
high performance computing systems some at
stanford summit texas and using this we can get
exactly the same results from you know software
run on very different systems okay finally
i want to mention the idea of automation
and so we try to to have our goal as being
to be able to for any particular workflow
we want to be able to rerun the entire workflow on
a new machine with a single command right i want
to be able to just put everything on a new you
know server and say go and have it do everything
give me all the same results that are exactly the
same as i would get anywhere else now a simple
tool for doing that that's surprisingly useful is
the make tool in unix um where you basically just
set up a make file and you know if you have
like a set of scripts that you need to run
um you can basically just say make all and it will
go do all those things and that's for simple stuff
that's what we end up using for more complicated
stuff um you know there's a number of different
workflow management packages some that are
specific to neural imaging so the night pipe
project allows you to basically you know mix
and match modules from a number of different
software packages into a single workflow that's
actually the basis for our fmri prep package
there's also some more general uh workflow
management tools focused on machine learning
so apache airflow metaflow from i think it's from
netflix um are a couple of them um so but it's
definitely important to be able to automate
everything because that then allows you to
to be able to run things one it's much easier for
you if anything changes you have new code you want
to test you basically just have one button to
push and everything goes one of the things that
we've started doing is using our test framework to
actually run analyses so you know we we've already
built testing right to make sure that the code
works but it's also possible to basically just
put your analyses into a test so basically
say hey i have you know i have all these 12
analyses i want to run i'm going to write each of
them as a test and then basically i can just say
hey pi test this directory and it goes and runs
all of those analyses you can see that in this
this is for our recent narps project all the
image analyses were um were defined as tests
so in this case you know it goes runs them takes
about 16 minutes to do that and it tells us hey
all the tests passed which means that none of the
analyses crashed now one of the benefits of this
is that you can then automate this further
using um a tool from software engineering
called continuous integration so continuous
integration is basically a system that re-runs
all the tests anytime anything changes in a code
repository so we use this for the darp study
where we you know we had a large code base and
obviously we were doing continuous development
on that each time we made a change to the code and
pushed it to to github that we set that to trigger
this system called circleci to basically grab
the code grab the docker container that defined
the platform grab the data that were needed for
running the analyses those were on zenodo and
basically run everything and tell us ultimately
did it succeed and one of the things you can
have it do is basically save all the results
out as an artifact and now you have your full
analysis run all the the results saved out that
you can basically just then hand over to somebody
now you know when we were doing this circle ci was
the the kind of platform of choice but now github
has its own continuous integration system called
github actions that is pretty easy to use and i
would recommend that okay so why why aren't we
there already why isn't everybody doing all this
stuff right well it's all about incentives um so
first like you know i've already shown you a bunch
of books and a bunch of new tools and all this
sort of stuff you have to learn you know who has
time to learn all that extra stuff right um it's
you know there we have a limited amount of time
and obviously learning this stuff is going to
take away from other stuff that you might do
and this combines with the fact that there's
little incentive for this for for one to do this
sort of stuff this is what happens if you put it
the academic job market is into google um and so
you know it's clear now that the the incentives
for people who are you know early career
researchers are all about publishing more right
not publishing papers that are more reproducible
simply publishing more papers in fancier
journals and any time you spend trying to
make your research more reproducible is almost
certainly going to result in fewer papers per
per amount of time so you know a number of us have
gotten very interested in you know what we can do
to to try to basically align these
incentives and there's currently a project
um that i've been involved in a little bit uh run
by the national academies called the round table
on aligning incentives for open science they're
soon going to be putting out a tool kit that's
largely meant for sort of universities to
um to you know kind of figure out how can we
make it so that you know people are incentivized
to do open and reproducible science and finally i
want to you know highlight an idea that has come
about recently you know udefrith wrote about this
recently in her um in tix but it's actually an
idea that's been around for at least a decade john
horgan wrote about it you know back in 2011 this
idea of slow science so udefrith says fast science
is bad for scientists and bad for science slow
science may actually help us make faster progress
and john morgan says i've expending i've
expended much of my career heaping calamity
on bad science why am i so opposed to the slow
science movement here's why i fear that if
scientists really slow down and start publishing
only high quality data and theories and have been
double and triple checked i won't have anything
left to write about right meaning that he won't
have bad science to trash on so just to summarize
i've tried to lay out you know a set of values
principles and practices that i think together
define how we can move towards not just you know
sort of saying that reproducibility is important
but having it be you know central and fundamental
to our to our research culture in neuroscience
and in data science more generally so finally i
want to thank my lab this is this is my lab circa
2020 um the way that we've been seeing each other
and mentioned that we just started a new center
at stanford as part of the data science institute
called the center for open and reproducible
science or cores which is going to be
developing infrastructure and um and tools to
help people do open science so with that i will
stop and be happy to take questions thank you so
much russ what a lot to think about in terms of
i'm just thinking of the picture in my head
of this layer cake of code development github
data workflows um continuous integration
and all this is being this infrastructure
for reproducible science um you made a point of
talking about this is the the sources of potential
places where reproducibility is probably really
important and then it's in terms of the variations
between computer systems whether you know big
indian little indian problems used to be the bane
of our existence um software errors and we've
seen several of those crop up in particular in
neuro imaging for example where statements about
probability of results happening was improperly
reported software libraries they change all the
time you got to recompile stuff and and all that
and you mentioned about um the portability of
the the methodologies um their provenance and
best practice i mean how can we do a better
job of making sure that all of those things
you touched on this in terms of peer-reviewed
publication what do the journals think of all this
i know you're as a journal editor yourself um this
must come up what do journals think about this
process that people need to go through um i think
it it's interesting question right i think it
varies across journals clearly you know some
journals are i think data sharing has been the
you know the probably the most prominent place
where this has come up and there's a number of
uh journals that are either requiring data sharing
like um you know like plus one or that are trying
to incentivize it by for example giving badges
like you know the psychological science does
um and they you know you can also have badges for
things like you know materials and code sharing
um i think that the challenge for the you know
nature the nature journals have also done some
various experiments like you know having people
upload things to code ocean um and um and i think
that you know they're still sort of struggling
with particularly how to manage the review
process around you know stuff that's you know
research objects beyond the paper right because
historically we've just reviewed the paper um
but um but you know it's clear to me having been
you know for example i reviewed one paper a few
years ago um where it was in a journal where they
shared the data and i it was you know i looked
closely at the data and i realized hey there's
a problem with what you've done the results are
probably due to an artifact here rather than
due to a real result um and that paper you know
may well have gotten published had they not shared
the code and and we've you've been able to see
that but that takes a lot of work on the reviewers
part right reviewers are already it's already hard
to find reviewers reviewers are already strapped
for time and so expecting them to do this is
challenging you know some journals have like
statistical editors who will actually look at
the statistical stuff but that doesn't mean that
they're able to like go in and actually run the
code obviously if it's if it's easily runnable
like if it's you know containerized or if it's
in a you know in something like one of these
sort of online platforms like binder or something
like that or code ocean then that makes it a lot
easier for people to do but you know it requires
that the the reviewers have expertise in it so i
think that's the big challenge i think the the
the journals many of the journals you know are
many of the top journals at least are very attuned
to the issues they just i think don't know how
to deal with the challenges of actually getting
people to review the code and the data yeah what
you've mentioned a number of different resources
um that's um places where people can share code
how they can link it up uh for example with the
circle ci thing i wasn't familiar with and that
sounds really interesting um but it seems like
not a day goes by at least from my perspective
there isn't some other new thing that i should
be attending to for how i should share my data
my code my results and uh how do it get that some
of them are brand new and some of them have a
big huge community around them for example like
the galaxy people just seem to like that's just
caught fire across the planet how do you kind of
filter these how do you know when something is
something you're going to go and tack your flag
to in terms of resources for trying to make things
reproducible yeah i mean i try not to be a super
early adopter me either i've been burned in some
ways like you know allow other people to kind of
do the exploration and then i can exploit once
they've found something so you know what i try
to do is like look at what other look at what the
like you know the early adopters in my particular
field are doing so for example you know we use
nypi like you know galaxy's taken off in a lot
of areas it hadn't really taken off in neuro
imaging as far as i could tell um and that's
you know in large part because there are other
you know um there are other sort of tools like
nypi that i think have become you know sort of
more popular and to the degree that there's a
domain specific tool or a field specific tool
i usually kind of you know tend towards those um
you know i so i think part of this is about like
you know really keeping your ear to the ground uh
in terms of like what the you know like what the
the people at the bleeding edge are doing and
then you know letting them kind of smooth things
out a bit so waiting you know if they're still
like if you hear them talking about you know
circle ci and they're still talking about it six
months later that's probably a good sign that's
a good sign that it actually sort of hung around
yeah cause i you know there are certain there's
certain early adopter people who i won't name
and i feel like every time i have a conversation
with with them i have to learn like 12 new
acronyms right because there's all these
new new projects they're talking about and and i
try to i try to let them smooth that over for me
i i i go through that same process myself
it's just try i just try to keep up now
i want to hear a little more about your kind
of personal journey here of how you started to
become an advocate for studying reproducibility
um in neuroscience um how you establish this
in your laboratory and what advice you might
have for young researchers who are just really
getting started building laboratory how do you
establish and get this culture underway in their
laboratories yeah um so i got you know so you
know i grew up as kind of an open source software
advocate i guess and so you know
even at the beginning of my career
i was you know sharing code i had a back
around like 2000 or so we had this spm
roi toolbox that you could use for like extracting
data from spm analyses that we shared openly so
i've always been an advocate for for kind of
you know code sharing and and openness um and
i think that's just kind of a philosophical thing
you know around how i think science should work
um the reproducibility stuff i became much more
attuned to around 2008 there was a um a paper that
when it was initially floated was titled voodoo
correlations in social neuroscience it ended up
with a different name but i saw the pre-print
and you know it highlighted this issue of of
a practice that people were doing in the neuro
imaging literature was basically double dipping
um with roi analyses and you know realized
that we had done that in some of our papers
um even though we weren't named you know in that
in the the paper by edville and colleagues um and
so started really trying to like you know dig
in dig more into the the nature of our methods
um and then you know soon thereafter came about
the the whole quote-unquote reproducibility crisis
that's kind of started in psychology um and and
that you know highlighting issues around like you
know questionable research practices p hacking
that sort of stuff and and again you know got
me realized that you know many of the things
that they were showing to be problematic were
things that pretty much every neuroimaging lab was
doing um and so that you know those things really
got me to start rethinking how we do science um
and so then when i moved to stanford i was lucky
enough to have two things happen one was chris
gorgolewski joined my lab as a postdoc he's now
moved on to google but you know he and i kind of
were able to build we're able to get a large grant
from the arnold foundation and build this um what
we call the center for reproducible neuroscience
which was the the the home of the open neuro
project we had started sharing data back around
2010 as part of this open fmri project and then
open neuro was kind of like the next generation
of that um and i you know obviously jack your
your early work was really inspiring around
you know data sharing and you know when it when
it finally really sort of took off around 2010
you know a lot of people were sharing wrestling
data we wanted to be in the business of sharing
tasks fmri data in particular and so you know
built some infrastructure around that and then
you know more recently i've been focusing
on bids as a as an essential part of the
infrastructure for data sharing um so that's
a long-winded way of kind of talking about
uh you know how i got here how have i established
a culture of code reproducibility in my lab
one is i think you know highlighting the
highlighting the the need to be thoughtful
and the need to kind of you know think about uh
how one writes code and having you know i think
that you know it's easy to just kind of write
code and assume that it works right if you don't
see any problems you assume that it works and i
try to you know more than anything instill this
sort of reflective philosophy about like you
know the fact that i i wrote a blog post a few
years ago talking about the principle of assumed
error this idea that like if you if you have an
analysis that quote unquote works that you should
basically assume you've done something wrong
and try to figure out what that might be and
you know we've had we've had interesting cases
in the lab where you know one of the post
docs had a result that looked really good um
but had for some reason like had a suspicion
that something funny might be going on and
it took this person at least a month of like
digging around off and on to find the error
that they had made in the code that when it was
fixed the result went away and this i mean and
this speaks to the kind of cost of reproducibility
i wrote a piece in neuron last year called the
cost of reproducibility right if you work that
way you're going to have fewer papers period
right this person probably could have published
a perfectly good paper on this interesting result
in a good journal that would have probably
never been uncovered because people are so
you know unlikely to actually try to replicate
any particular findings or like dig through
code even if the code was shared it's unlikely
anybody would have put put in the work to find
that problem this is a person whose you know
career-wise false discovery rate is going to
be low right it's a person whose work you can
trust um but unfortunately you know that that
kind of trust is not the thing that gets
you jobs right or gets you tender oh um
so people you know my trainees publish relatively
little compared to other labs like i had two phds
recently who both walked out with like one
you know they had a few like smaller papers
but one kind of big paper one was one was a pnas
paper one was a nature communications paper so
i think they were high impact papers but they
aren't published they don't have these long cds
because they're not like cranking things out
if you kind of you know have a a factory that
cares less about replicing um and that's a to
these people i think that um you know ultimately
you know they've been able to go on and and do
good things in their careers um but um but it
you know speaks to one of the one of the questions
is there like you know this it one can get dinged
for not being productive no i should say you
know i there are people i know um in the field
who have always published relatively little um
but when they publish something it's really good
um and so i think it's you know there's there's
room for those type of people but it's it can be
hard to it can be hard to get the job as that
sort of person once you have the job it's i
think people can get tenured you know if they can
show that hey i publish one paper a year but it's
a really good paper rather than publishing you
know five papers a year and having them all just
kind of be you know sort of factory stuff um but
it's a i think the only way to fix this issue is
by i think there's there's it has to happen
from two directions one is changing from the top
right that university presidents and provosts
department chairs you know senior faculty all
need to change the way they think about like how
we judge people for hiring promotion and tenure
and at the same time we do pressure from below
where you know fields need to push to you know
push everybody in that uh particular discipline
to do open science and the way that i think for
example the the you know oh the human brain
mapping organization has it's interesting
that you know i remember a relatively you know
famous senior person a few years ago complaining
at an ohbm meeting that you know that the open
science zealots had taken over the organization
fast forward five years and this person is now one
of the biggest advocates for open science so that
you know that kind of change can happen pretty
quickly when there's a lot of pressure from the
bottom um but i think we also need the pressure
from the top uh yeah i agree uh well i think
with that's a great uh place to end and i want to
thank you dr polderak for for sharing your your
thoughts and uh your your ideas about reproducible
science about how to implement it and uh tools for
so doing and sharing us with your personal story
and ideas about how to implement this in in the
laboratories of the young investigators who are
joining us today um so thank you once again thank
you to everybody who joined us um everybody have a
great weekend and we'll see you next week for our
next uh installment in this uh seminar series so
thank you everyone take care all right thanks bile